natalie amiri ist unsere korrespondentin
in teheran und zuständig für den iran
natalie in diesem falle schönen guten
abend nach münchen natalie was bedeutet
diese ermordung des generals zu lehman
ii für den iran
es bedeutet dass der iran massiv damit
verletzt wurde
nicht nur militärisch sondern auch hat
er sein gesicht verloren und das
versucht der iran jetzt gerade wieder
zurechtzubiegen indem er den gesamten
tag schon von lauter sowohl von der iss
militärischen ecke also von der islam
schneise von der regierungsseite droht
mit massiven vergeltungsschlägen
außerdem solle man nie war der general
dass er an er hatte kultstatus man hatte
sogar auf instagram und telegramm
fanseiten über ihn es gab t shirts mit
seinen bild darauf gedruckt er war der
chefstratege für ausländische einsätze
des iran in der region er hat vor allen
dingen in syrien und im irak stark
agiert er hat zusammen mit schiitischen
milizen dort gearbeitet sie aufgebaut
militärisch beraten mal es heißt auch
dass baschar el assad überhaupt nicht
der präsident des von syrien heute noch
wäre hätte es trotzdem solle man ihn
nicht gegeben also insofern er ist eine
enorm schillernde figur für den iran für
die iranische strategie auch ideologisch
militärisch aber natürlich eine
gemeingefährliche person für die
amerikaner schon immer gewesen und
deswegen stand er lange auf der liste
der todes feinde der amerikaner der
vereinigten staaten
da passt es ja gut dass wir gleich um 18
uhr meine damen und herren hier im
anschluss eine doku über kassel sulimani
haben natalie also die letzten stunden
hat jetzt der iranische sicherheitsrat
in teheran getagt die new york times hat
berichtet alle mitglieder hätten eine
schriftliche aufforderung des
revolutionsführers ali khamenei bekommen
ihm genau dem gleichen ausmaß müsse
jetzt gegen die usa zurück geschlagen
werden was ist aus ihrer sicht jetzt zu
erwarten
naja die sätze die sich etwas
abgesondert haben von den normalen
statements die man so aus dem iran hört
war dass sie aufs schärfte aufs
schärfste diesen angriff verurteilt
haben und gesagt haben es war der größte
strategische fehler der amerikaner den
sie bisher begangen haben und sie werden
dafür auf jeden fall
vergeltungsmaßnahmen bekommen wann und
wo ist noch nicht ganz genau sicher
spannend war auch dass der nationale
sicherheitsrat zum ersten mal unter der
leitung mit dem revolutionsführer des
landes ali khamenei getagt hat das zeigt
auch die brisanz der situation und man
es bleibt abzuwarten die nächsten
stunden tage wie diese
vergeltungsmaßnahmen aussehen aber der
iran hat ja in der region überall
verbündete und milizen aufgestellt und
verbündete haben auch schon die milizen
jetzt aufgerufen in alarmbereitschaft zu
sein und sich für die schlacht
schlechthin vorzubereiten verstehe ich
sie richtig das sicherlich nicht mit
einem schlag irans direkt gegen die usa
oder gegen amerikanische einrichtungen
zu rechnen ist sondern eher mit
stellvertreter schlägen also von
möglicherweise schiitischen milizen im
irak oder auch in anderen teilen der
welt
naja wenn man logisch von der im
momentanen wirtschaftlichen und
militärischen stärke dass iran ausgeht
kann sich der iran so einen direkten
angriff auf die amerikaner gar nicht
leisten
das würde wieder eine
vergeltungsmaßnahme mit sich bringen und
auf dauer würde der iran militärisch das
nicht überstehen und innenpolitisch ist
ja sowieso wirtschaftlich stark
angeschlagen durch die us-sanktionen der
letzten eineinhalb jahre also geht man
davon aus experten sagen es wird wohl
wieder vergeltungsschläge in diesen
proxy wars regionen also in diesen
stellvertreter regionen geben und es
wird man wird sehen wie massiv die
ausfallen dieses mal
jetzt haben sie die bevölkerung schon
angesprochen was wir hier ja in
zentraleuropa vielleicht wenig
mitbekommen sind ja diese massiven
sanktionen gegen den iran jetzt schon
seit monaten laufen was bedeutet das was
wir jetzt erlebt haben also der schlag
der usa gegen sulejmani und die
angekündigte vergeltung auch für die
bevölkerung im iran
na das kann zum einen in die richtung
laufen das ist das fass zum überlaufen
bringt auch im iran weil sie sagen diese
außenpolitische druck und innenpolitisch
schafft man das auch nicht mehr kommen
wir noch mal auf die straße
ich gehe aber im moment davon aus denn
in so einer situation zieht der
geheimdienst anzeigen sich
sicherheitskräfte auf der straße
wir hören auch von kampfhubschraubern
die ort von mehreren städten auch in
alarmbereitschaft sind also ich gehe
davon aus dass die bevölkerung sich
jetzt nicht traut auf die straße so
bekommen wie wir es jetzt vor einem
monat gesehen haben als die proteste
auch brutalst niedergeschlagen wurden
und innerhalb von drei tagen nur 1500
allein in drei tagen 1500 menschen
umgebracht wurden von sicherheitskräften
der islamischen republik also ich gehe
er davon aus dass es im moment von der
bevölkerung eher still ruhe geben wird
und dass im bevölkerungsreichsten
kontinent auf die straße kamen um für
das system und gegen die amerikaner zu
protestieren und den tod von krems
alemany zu beklagen
natalie amiri unsere korrespondentin in
teheran normalerweise für die region und
für iran jetzt in münchen fielen dankt
ihnen für die gesamten einschätzung und
wir hören uns sicherlich noch ein paar
mal in den nächsten tagen wahrscheinlich